[Music]
if fun cop news [ __ ] up our cops are fun
kind of like the hops all fun cops like
you're having too much fun freeze put on
your pants
yeah what Oh fun police hold on your
pants
depends on which region submitted by
breakfast that's my favorite meal of the
day you know that we're good right now
what kind of like American breakfast or
all kind of breakfast that's why you're
good dude but also delicious food corner
Oh China oh I was gonna get delicious
food quarter before I came here today
why didn't Joe why don't you tell you to
me because I was late as [ __ ] so I
couldn't get it I missed that place
where you got was just food corner right
here on Garfield Hong Kong breakfast
location right here in Hong Kong that
place has like whatever reviews they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about them what the fingers pulled back
well most of those bad reviews from
Chinese restaurants is because service
or something yeah it's not because of
the food they should have different
section II should it's like food here
service here ambiance here you want to
cry about [ __ ] insects here bathroom
over here cuz insects have nothing to do
with the food okay loud customers here
sometimes there's ants and flies but the
food's bomb delicious food corridor
delicious food corner got you
police responded to a noise complaint
but wound up playing video games with
the men in question
that's tight smash bros i always say
that cuz that's the only game I play is
it fun bash bros ultimate the new one I
just can't ask pretty crazy well I
played that old one the first one I've
never played any of them well it's just
this thinking like a Nintendo game caste
just a stupid same caste
yeah now GameCube or Dreamcast Dreamtime
I guess Dreamcast is Sony and Sega
Dreamcast Sega Dreamcast yes Sega
Sega Dreamcast Sega Dreamcast game
station nintendo 63
yeah there is 69 stupid let's continue
these police officers in Minnesota were
called to a noise complaint
noise noise and so they're being boys
down the road well what is that siren or
money
it's Lois from Family Guy okay so know
you found a road we suck what cops got
there they were talking to the guys
there and they were like hey yeah you
know we called for noise complaint and
the guys were like well we have just
been keeping the same noise level oh we
always do I mean I don't know we just
have neighbors I like to complain and
then the customer like a mean you guys
are pretty respectful you're not being
that loud so what game were you guys
playing and they're like super smash
bros there and then they were like oh oh
they were like do you want to play and
then two or three of the cops were like
yeah I want to play how many cops showed
up the whole SWAT team they all take off
our masks and there's like a body armor
[ __ ]
javante is one of the guys that would
show Fonte yeah so neighbors called the
cops in on us and now we fighting them
in smash bros hashtag all's matter
follow me on instagram twitter a job
that you know we follow my page to
Jovita like people go a little viral now
they have to add like oh yeah by the way
follow me check out my art yeah yeah for
different reasons you just comment on
somebody else's content you're like hey
check out my page yeah 100% - nobody
ever follows you after yeah just to let
you know how the cops are in there in
this video that's dope that was the
college game Oh Smash Bros man it was
fun
I do like it when the cops make an
attempt to kind of build that social
rapport connect and it brings like
humanity to it so you're not so fearful
and you're like cops are just people to
like when they take off the uniform
their dads moms brothers whatever pet
owners the thing I'm thinking about is
like should they be working I know you
know like they're like answering a call
and then you never like answering the
call on the way home they're about to be
off duty and then right when the guy
asks is like the clock hit I hope so
well I don't get it don't get that
dispatch if some [ __ ] goes down they'll
be like oh we got our rock
like oh she got more control this is I
called out we gotta finish this game
give that basketball court that was
played in Pasadena yeah Cali for a
shooting and then one of the cops came
by T he started shooting with this too
she was a little weird
I felt I felt like I could yeah yeah the
belt angel I mean he he took his other
side ofyou it's his partners but there
was two other cops there and he gave it
to them and they would play but I feel
weird guarding a cop in his [ __ ]
outfit his whole outfit and he couldn't
really do what he want cuz it was so
stiff did you keep reaching for the
pepper so weird cause I was like hi this
feels odd enough I was a guard you or
not yeah but yeah the guy you came in he
just ready oh can I get a couple shots
in like it would have had to heal
substantially better than me but it was
it was pretty I follow a cop in Hawaii
his name was shots - Craig Konami I
think and this fall is always skating
with kids and then he's always doing
like BJ Jane on the side always in his
for cop outfit he probably only has a
couple hundred uh didn't follow spice
thing is dope that he's do you find him
probably on the explore page I just see
like a guy in full cop outfit doing kick
flips and [ __ ] and then on my I gotta
fall there's never get cool stuff like
that on my explore page dude guys get
like how to make pancakes how to make
like a hamburger I feel like they're
really receptive nowadays like they know
what you're looking at they listen to
you
well my shits all wrong imagine it's
just a pit just like takes a screenshot
of your face and they just assume all
you want is food it's also that and
there's a lot of we type kickboxing
mine's all animes yeah my shits like 50%
fitness and kid [ __ ] and I'm like why
kitchen cuz they're listening to you
everything that you talked about they're
probably like this guy might be a kid
it's like the oddest mix right so it's
like a lot of fitness stuff which I
don't know why cuz I don't [ __ ] work
out I do but not like that
there's karate that makes sense maybe
it's cuz your friend
yeah you follow that father what it is
cuz definitely my Discover page had like
a couple like buff hot dudes one time
and I was like huh how's this and I
realize some people are followed I need
to follow some like very hot women so
they they could come up on mix board
place because all I get is bloody men
yeah weird they're all bloody there's a
face is smashed in from I get all of
those that will 100% work if you fall
like one or two hot people and then you
just go down maybe some things that are
connected with them guarantee the next
day oh you're liking every hot girls
page I have a lot of animal [ __ ] just
animals like I don't know why I just
like enjoy watching animals in all
social network platforms I like animals
for like cuteness but also survival for
food yeah when they eat Wow
no I I want to eat them Oh disagree I
mean innocent I said easy no mine is all
like DIY stuff and life hack stuff and
then like make up stuff I don't even
look at make up stuff I think I follow
people that follow people that have
makeup sex I would prefer make up stuff
make up stuff is interesting is its
soothing [ __ ] porn to me oh really I
like watching this [ __ ] like in terms of
watching somebody apply makeup is
soothing yeah well cause it's art I mean
it's just the canvas is skin now right
but it's the same concept makeup is so
much like painting it's like I get tired
looking at it because I see like how
many different like brushes and Lovings
and products other than I'm like oh my
god how much money did you spend on all
this it's time to about those makeup
things it's like it's really cool what
they do but I would never want to have
the person that I'm with looks like them
good makeup I never want to look like
that exactly it looks like art but then
what I want that person they look like
that I'm with look like no cuz it's not
real cuz it makes sense by themselves
but then if you take that person and
then plug them into society like they're
just not you they stick out so there's
so much makeup like you can literally
grab their face and take it off yeah
it's okay then right like it's totally
okay to like be into like makeup stuff
when they do like that and not be okay
with it being like within your own
circle and you don't live as a
preference yeah yeah these are perfect I
don't care if like anyone here had that
I'd be like
admiring and I'd want to watch it I'm
just saying from
so that's just not I mean I barely wear
makeup now because there's like makeup
girls that I've met him in real life
versus their photos and their photos the
makeup looks great but you see them in
real life it literally let such cake on
like a [ __ ] and I'm like dude when
you smile I could see the makeup
crusting on your face yeah yeah yeah
then they give you a hug and you just
have makeup in the photos it looks
natural and if they do it for a camera
so much I don't think they do it for in
real life purposes so when you see it
it's just it's very apparent yeah I just
look at that shingle
can we hurry up and leave already like
that once like all like super glammed up
and like the craziest eyelashes and I
was like oh my god it was this person I
don't like it you know I don't mind more
extreme art I think when it's like your
extreme for regular like societal like
stuff that's what I'm like wallet that's
extreme as long as you know it's the
stream but it's like somebody goes more
extreme and it's more like theatrical
I'm like that's really cool to me like
the RuPaul drag race team more accepting
to me in the sense of like not trying to
either go all-in or you're not yeah yeah
but like in makeup just to like you know
do your day to day like that that's when
it gets if it's extreme that's what I'm
like I don't understand that yeah but
like what school does is that these DIYs
and stuff they're helping out girls who
don't have anyone to teach them how to
put on makeup right so now it's like
everyone looks legit like I was just on
Instagram the other day just looking I'm
thinking damn you know what like we grew
up with a lot of ugly people like in our
generation like know how to use their
makeup well yeah they're not ugly yeah
you're right you're it's just uh
they took him a long time when I stood
in the world of deception now all of us
do like like we don't know how to dress
like we didn't know how to do anything
but now it's like maybe your parents
can't teach her they don't know or
whatever you could just look at
tutorials online and understand like oh
this is how you're supposed to wear a
real [ __ ] feeding pants you know like
spice are you supposed to kids don't
look like kids anymore man that's true
like kids but a little grown-ass adults
and they said that for our generation
too but then you take then today's
generation it's like whoa like be really
only even little girls not like makeup
and stuff on yeah man it's our easy
give these sell crop tops for a little
like three-year-old [ __ ] that [ __ ] rock
top yeah I'm still tripping out that
every kid damn plant has like a cell
phone it'll at least in my planning how
old are these kids in our plan man no
I'm just saying like all like all the
little tykes that are around like
families not like everyone's got like
cell phones and stuff into my mind I'm
like the [ __ ] calling you kid I know
exactly what important business call do
you have I do understand that maybe in
your dad's role because they need to
contact the kid to pick them up in class
maybe they're texting their friends oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I knew and when you're
like eight or something and yeah
everyone other cell phone guys be
talking all the time that's evert that's
their version of our like expensive
Mikey [ __ ] that dude if I get a kid
they're getting a goat cool that is very
cool that's your entertainment hopefully
hopefully I don't know like I don't know
I'm not a parent yet but if I you get a
goat or a chicken
no milk it's an iPhone he's like I could
get him a knife one of my plan I'm like
why does he need an iPhone damn I see
like kids that my older friends have and
they're their kids and they made it a
point to make sure that this is
something that they're highly dependent
on and it was a hit and miss for some
kids right but the ones that weren't so
dependent and they like it but they're
not dependent on they they're actually
be most successful in terms of how they
think yeah their default isn't to go to
this you know they'd like to explore
like one kid that I know he's going to
her mind right now became like the dorm
whatever you know that but we are a the
RNA became an RA he has like his housing
for free now he when he was in high
school he worked as an internship and
appaled and all this other great stuff
and he's the kid that doesn't depend on
this so much he interacts he cooks for
his parents he like he likes to
experiment the kitchen he does a little
bit of everything and I see that I think
it was just highly because of how she
raised the kid and kind of put like
importance and stuff outside of just
stuff like this which is really cool me
you give me this thank goodness I didn't
grow up with this when I was a kid it's
because I was already [ __ ] playing
video games and jacking off all day long
imagine
bug
[Music]